uh so let's talk about art and what it
means when we reflect it through the
lens of AI we start with a candid
message from Google's CEO about
artificial intelligence he says it will
impact everything on last night's 60
Minutes CEO Sundar pichai gave Scott
Pelley an inside look into the company's
new AI chatbot it is called Bard Bard
spent several months reading everything
on the internet to create its own
communication model pelly asked Barr to
do a few simple tasks then he asked Bard
to get creative with a famous short
story which Barr did with mind-blowing
speed
we played with a famous six-word short
story often attributed to Hemingway
for sale baby shoes never worn wow the
only prompt we gave was finish this
story
in five seconds
holy cow
the shoes were a gift from my wife but
we never had a baby they were from the
six word prompt Bard created a deeply
human tale with characters it invented
including a man whose wife could not
conceive and a stranger grieving after a
miscarriage and longing for closure
uh I am rarely speechless
I don't know what to make of this
give me we asked for the story in verse
in five seconds there was a poem written
by a machine with breathtaking insight
into the mystery of faith
Bard wrote she knew her baby's Soul
would always be alive
the humanity at superhuman speed was a
shock
all right so we're going to talk about
this but let me also point out the 68
minutes also visited a AI lab it's
Google's AI lab it's called deepmind
deepmind has made a number of incredible
breakthroughs in artificial intelligence
among them Scott watched robots that
play soccer here's the thing they were
not programmed to play they learned the
game by themselves I know Gail I know
it's wild Google's Bard is also teaching
itself new things which the company
can't even explain and that you might
find a little scary listen
some AI systems are teaching themselves
skills that they weren't expected to
have
how this happens is not well understood
for example one Google AI program
adapted on its own after it was prompted
in the language of Bangladesh which it
was not trained to know
we discovered that with very few amounts
of prompting in Bengali you can now
translate all of Bengali so now all of a
sudden we now have a research effort
where we're now trying to get to a
thousand languages there is an aspect of
this which we call all of us in the
field call it as a black box you know
you don't fully understand and you can't
quite tell why it said this or why it
got wrong we have some ideas and our
ability to understand this gets better
over time but that's where the state of
the art is you don't fully understand
how it works and yet you've turned it
loose on society yeah let me put it this
way I don't think we fully understand
how a human mind works either
all right so we've been talking about I
know it it is I see why Scott was
speechless honestly it's a little scary
to me it's it's it's it's fascinating it
is frightening um I'm of the mind and
and Sundar pinch I mentioned this um
that to me this art that it's creating I
don't know that I'd call it Humanity I I
you know uh to me it can learn how to
play sports but can it respond to Little
Johnny Sylvester in 1926 as Babe Ruth
did and promised to hit him a home run
and then go on to hit three home runs in
the 1926 World Series for Little John
and then the kid miraculously recovers
you know can it float like a butterfly
and sting like a bee and Jive uh
suddenly listen to win the heavyweight
champion in 1967 a very smart guy but
even he was like saying I don't know all
the answers here well yeah to everything
that is happening the art question it's
a little listen I watched the movie
Megan on the plane over the weekend yeah
I know people are going to laugh at me
and say Gail that's a movie but I
thought it raised some very interesting
questions and I know it's just a movie
Sundar is correct and saying that we
don't understand how the human mind
works the difference is we didn't put
the human mind here right some other
power data now we are playing that power
and by their own admission it's a black
box teaching itself stuff we don't
understand why teaching himself how to
do things we don't understand how right
that is frightening and to the question
is Bard safe Which Scott asked he said I
think so I think so based on how we're
doing it now exactly I think so so much
I'm bundled there we're going to keep
talking about it but now we've got to
talk about the Netflix show love is
blind turns out love is blind because no
one got to see it yesterday fans were
disappointed when they logged on to
watch the highly anticipated season four
live reunion a technical glitch laid
this special for more than an hour
co-host Vanessa Lachey shared this video
on social media while they worked out
the problem watch
we are sitting here apparently y'all
everybody broke the end
we're ready to roll so we are ready to
roll we just gotta figure this out I
know people were hot so they didn't go
we are live live every day
with us time now for what to watch no
need to look above Nate girl listens
back at the table
air hug from everybody
so you've been in Jamaica yeah that's
right in the Bahamas that's right you've
been to Vegas I went to Vegas and I
visited our affiliate klas they showed
us
that's Jamaica um that's me hanging out
with my 17 year old and that's the whole
crew your first time in Jamaica first
time in Jamaica and shout out to
everybody at Jamaica they showed us a
ton of Love listen visit Jamaica it is
one of the most beautiful places is that
your wife wearing like the Jamaica like
flag you know we got to represent yeah
and you're on a raft there did you guys
yep I I did a little bit of everything
you know we wanted to go off the grid
and then also experience the culture and
the food and that was everything so we
always joke whenever Tony and I are like
well when Nate goes on vacation for the
first day he shows off his abs shows off
his muscles but by the end of the
presentation after you eating drinking
we'd never see you shirtless yeah no I
didn't go shirtless on this one because
I didn't have my body right watch it nah
I got that Dad Bob popping up under here
I don't believe it I don't believe it
either I don't believe it was it tough
to come back
okay open I always think it's great to
go away but it's always nice to come
back it was it was it was a long enough
trip where I did actually miss being at
work so I'm happy to be back yeah yeah
also for a little while we're missing
part of your body a little bit of a
we'll talk about that later we're gonna
get in we're gonna call that a tease
wait wait wait missing part of your body
yeah yeah
you guys want to stick around for talk
at the table later in the show uh we're
gonna try to bring a little joy and
light uh to what to watch this morning
uh we have a big update on the story
that CBS News has covered for decades uh
so beginning here first after being free
for two years a Florida man is headed
back to prison for murder he says he did
not commit you'll recall 65 year old
Crosley green surrendered to the Florida
Department of Corrections on Monday
after losing his final bid to remain at
home with his family earlier this month
the State of Florida ordered green to
return to prison after the U.S Supreme
Court declined to hear his appeal green
spent 32 years in prison for a murder
that he says he did not commit including
19 on death row a federal judge
overturned his conviction back in 2018
ruling that Green's right to a fair
trial had been violated an appeals court
then reversed that ruling Green's
attorneys are seeking either clemency
from Florida's governor or parole from
the state Aaron Moriarty is going to
have a lot more on this case uh on 48
hours Saturday next to the case though
Vlad I mean but they're not looking at
the facts that's the thing it's all
technicalities and paperwork no one's
looking at the question of was he
innocent in the first place or not and
even if he receives that clemency or the
state intervenes somehow it's not going
to absolve him of this crime but he made
such Tony a very compelling case about
how he didn't do it right many people
involved in the case say that he didn't
do it
yes they did the jurors recanted
although I will say that the young woman
now not young anymore but when she was
19 who pointed him out yeah in the
lineup she believes that he is the one
who committed the murder and killed her
boyfriend she still believes that
speaking of not young anymore can you
imagine spending 32 years behind bars
then you get out he was a free man he's
eating ice cream he was playing with so
he was living his life again and now
he's got to go back go back but he kept
saying I have faith in the system it'll
work out for me is it wrong to say I
might actually have thought about
running yeah I'm serious all right I
might have thought about running looking
at going back into prison when you've
been there for 32 years some of them on
death row for a crime you you say and
you believe you did not commit and
evidence shows you did not I might think
about running right well Aaron Moriarty
is going to have more on this on
Saturday for 48 hours she's been
covering this story since the late 80s
so yeah Aaron's all over it uh okay uh
over the years we've seen some scary
moments when Intruders got through the
fence at the White House right yeah and
sometimes Secret Service agents actually
draw their guns it happened yesterday
but this time authorities got a
pint-sized surprise
a toddler
a toddler squeezed through the metal
fence uh briefly entered the White House
grounds officers quickly scooped up the
child the Secret Service spokesman said
that White House security systems
instantly triggered Secret Service
officers and the toddler and his parents
were quickly reunited you wouldn't think
a toddler could that that little boy
could fit through those bars do you oh
they're kind of wide yeah I'm not
surprised I'm also not surprised that a
toddler went for it right exactly it's
like if there's bars a baby's gonna be
like I'm gonna try to go through that
and watch out it happened I know it does
time now for what to watch with vladuce
but Vlad if I could I had a little bit
of breaking news from the world of
baseball uh the Oakland Athletics who
have been in Oakland for more than 50
years drawing just 11 000 fans on
average a game this year in the Coliseum
have signed a deal to build a new
stadium in Las Vegas wow near the West
End of the strip wow now it's not a
final final they're going to move there
but they're investing that is a binding
deal to buy the land and build a stadium
big news looks like this is happening
big things are happening in Vegas I love
Vegas I love baseball this is like my
favorite combo I also love the fact that
they kept Boogie Wonderland as you were
reading that story because they're
moving to Vegas and if there's a Boogie
Wonderland in America
Las Vegas just snatching teams from
Oakland we'll take the Raiders yes we'll
take place
that's really interesting formula One's
Gonna Be formula one yeah
wow that is breaking news
oh man yes we'll be there next year we
will be there maybe you but
no no Paramount mountain is going to be
there that's right let's just say this
we all want to go that's right on the
record just put that out there Vegas I
love you that's my vision board I love
you uh all right let's start here uh
with new trouble for Creed Three Star
Jonathan Majors sources to a variety
that multiple women have come forward
after his March arrests on a domestic
violence charge claiming Majors abuse
them the report says these women are
cooperating with the Manhattan District
Attorney's office and a statement is
returning to a variety the actor is
innocent and has not abused anyone the
statement says they have provided quote
irrefutable evidence that the charges
are false Majors was arrested last month
on charges of strangulation assault and
harassment after a 30-year-old woman
told police he had assaulted her
following the incident a series of text
messages allegedly sent by the woman was
released by Majors Camp it claims the
message is exonerated him but others who
have read them see it differently Majors
is due to appear in court next month and
the future of his career has become
uncertain since the accused Nations
majors has been dropped by his
management and his publicist as well as
several projects that he has in
development and the woman involved in
that incident allegedly was allegedly
involved in a relationship with him it
wasn't just a minor woman supposedly but
a random woman I meant to say but it's
just very these these latest allegations
are very disturbing they're troubling
that's the investigation continues uh
and we'll see where it leads yes not
good looking good all right today is
April 20th Gail do you know what that is
I know it has something to do with
marijuana all right
Tony I know you know
uh 420. it is
uh today of celebration for marijuana
Tony I know you know
the latest CBS News no denial over here
he was just like Haley Nelson was like
yeah yeah attitudes are changing that's
right this is exactly right uh so we
have a new poll out that shows that
Americans attitudes around marijuana are
changing a slight majority in that poll
53 now considers open use open use of
marijuana to be socially acceptable now
that's a shift from two years ago when
53 percent told us it was socially
unacceptable so that's kind of a big
jump uh we also asked occasional pot
users who knows you use marijuana this
is revealing right this is very
interesting 44 said most of their
friends and their family know about it
34 say some do and some don't and 22 say
very few or no one and get this most
Americans in our poll said they would
not think less of any person for using
marijuana that includes most of the
people who hardly ever or never use
marijuana themselves in other words no
I have never tried I've never tried it I
am curious I have never tried it but I
don't think listen I'm sure somebody
here could help you out Gail you never
tried it yeah I'm kidding as far as I
know we're the only one in the building
here who's ever attempted it but I mean
I think it's very revealing you know one
time in college as an experiment wait
vlad's just dry snitching on them
one day I can like mock everybody
instead of being the object of mockery
hello Jared
that man literally wears a hat with a
bud leaf on it some days
so much more to say uh all right social
media let me tone it down for just a
little bit uh one of the things that
gives me great joy is when we get to
follow up on some of the amazing people
that we get to introduce you to so in
2020 we brought you the story of an
incredible young man his name reihon
Stanton he was attending daily remember
the University of Maryland and he had a
job as a sanitation worker his
co-workers encouraged him to apply to
law school he did and he was accepted at
Harvard watch this moment
I'm clicking it
congratulations congratulations
let's go
so when we shared statin's story it
caught the attention of movie and TV
producer Tyler Perry he offered to pay
Stanton's Law School tuition and he
asked that the young scholar paid the
generosity Ford well what do you know
that's exactly what statin is doing just
a month away from graduation my man
reached out to me with an update on his
time at Harvard he shared an experience
from last February where he greeted the
custodian to see how she was doing her
response really shocked him she said I'm
sorry I didn't know you were talking to
me students would usually rather look at
the wall than talk to me that response
inspired Stanton to start a non-profit
organization called the reciprocity
effect to bring support staff and
students closer together the reciprocity
effect officially launched last Monday
with the ceremony to honor and and to
give light to the support staffers who
demonstrate outstanding leadership
community building and artistic skills
right yeah great update love you Rayhan
keep doing it it's Friday y'all I know
uh we have a lot to talk about but
before we get to some of our stories can
we just talk about Twitter for just yeah
about the blue check marks uh so uh Elon
Musk finally made good on his promise to
remove blue check marks from those
accounts that were verified
um and there are a lot of people who
have verified uh Twitter accounts who
have said that they are not going to pay
that eight dollars or only three people
did you know that he's paying for three
people you know who they are
LeBron Stephen King and William Shatner
he said I don't know I don't know but
like but they've all said that they were
not going to pay for it um why this is I
think problematic for a lot of people
it's not the eight dollars it's the fact
that there are people who perhaps are
not always as Savvy as those Media
Insiders we happen to be Media Insiders
who will see perhaps a tweet look at
this tweet here from the New York City
Government right so this is really
interesting so the city of New York
tweeted this is an authentic Twitter
account representing New York City
Government this is the only account for
NYC gov run by New York City Government
but then look below that it says no
you're not this is the account this is
the only authentic Twitter account
representing and run by the New York
City Government so imagine there's
another superstorm standing yes and you
need information or imagine there's
something even worse like another 911
differentiate one from the other that
was the point of the verified it's not I
know that people take it to mean that
it's an elitist thing and it sets up a
caste system in social media I'm not I'm
not an animal I'm not a media analyst
you got to pay the eight dollars no I'm
not yeah okay yeah I mean yeah yeah I'm
not going to I haven't tweeted in a
month my wife's been off for a whole
year has she really yeah yeah I was sock
puppeting her Twitter account for a
while just because she had book
promotional stuff right that was me
folks yeah oh that's funny but um yeah I
mean we are the people that know you
will know you and if it isn't you can
easily say no that's not me there is a
way to do that there's a for you uh um
vertical on your Twitter feed that is
going to be the people that you follow
it's the one that is I'm sorry you're
following vertical is the one that you
want the for you that's very chaotic but
that government example you gave though
of that is a really good example that's
something to think about yeah